Do I believe that Laccari or Dr. Disrespect are pedophiles? No,
I don't. And you want to know why? Because if they were, they'd
be in jail. >> Not even EDP is in jail, bro. What are YOU
SAYING? LIKE
>> OH, THAT'S SO GOOD, BRO. THAT That'll That'll That's
not even funny.
We'll do the Techtown thing for a little bit here. Okay. All
right, let's check it out. Let's just check out this video. 12
minutes. Apparently, he says all kinds of totally insane things
here about Dr. Disrespect,
Basically, implying that there's like no proof he did anything
wrong.
I don't know how he possibly gets around the literal confession
that he was being inappropriate with a minor. I did That's very
That's very confusing to me. I don't
I don't know.
I don't quite get it. How you could have this opinion.
It's very baffling, but let's check it >> Welcome back
to the dumb ass [__] that streamers do every single
day. It's
Today, we're actually going to talk about Dr. Disrespect. So,
if you actually don't know about Dr. Disrespect, Dr. Disrespect
was one of the most successful streamers of all time. Blew up
in H1Z1, blew up in PUBG, played a great character of a man with
sunglasses and a mustache. I mean, you you guys probably know
this guy, right? The guy This guy Guy Beahm. Anyways, he admitted
to cheating on his wife once, and apparently his wife forgave
him. They have a kid, they stayed together. I'm not really one
to really tell people how to live their lives. At least not in
this scenario. I don't think cheating is ever admissible whatsoever.
But then there was also the biggest scandal of all because some
people are willing to overlook cheating, but there was a bigger
scandal like maybe three, four years ago now,
and I'm always very hesitant
big controversies involving whoever's on top. And everybody who's
on top has a massive target on their back. So, when those people,
like like for example, everything that's being said about Hassan,
I will always take with a grain of salt and make sure to verify
everything that I can before ACTUALLY BELIEVING IT. OH, that's
not true. Doesn't this guy do the whole brothel thing? He he
says lies about Hassan all the time. What the [__]
is he talking
What the [__] is this guy talking about,
I I feel like Teccy Tone does this Oh, he did [__]
about Miss Kif too? He he just makes [__] up. What
the [__]
Same thing with me, same thing with like a shroud, same thing
with like uh you know uh Oh, also, Dr. Disrespect was not on
top anymore. He was still like a big streamer, but he was gone
from Twitch. He he didn't reach the same level of prominence,
right? He was doing like well, but I think he got demonetized
before this, didn't he, on
I thought he also got demonetized on YouTube before this happened,
or maybe it was after. I can't totally remember.
And then he went to Rumble. Oof. Um like a Magnus of chess, because
the people on top, everybody's trying to take them down any means
possible, because until the kingpin is removed, then all those
underneath cannot grow. And Dr. Disrespect is a guy with a massive
target on his back, because he was the number one FPS streamer
in his time. But one of the biggest controversies that happened
was, and these are Dr. Disrespect's exact words, that he had
a inappropriate conversation
with a minor
over Twitch DMs. Now, that statement was later redacted.
And in the court of law,
a judge went into all the information,
and he said that nothing illegal
And that's what's very interesting and that How does Tectone
know that? He just said something I've never seen that. I think
they had a civil case, right?
Does he mean retracted? He means deleted like Dr. Disrespect
deleted his
But in a court of law they said nothing illegal happened.
I don't even know if that's possibly
It sounds like there was some evidence put forward in civil court
that was never pursued in criminal court. But even then
if you were if you were trying to a minor and you just failed
you just failed you failed before you cross the finish line
I don't know like
we can just talk about it morally.
But I think Tectone's going to have to you know this will be
all about Tectone trying to make it so if you don't get a criminal
charge you're not you're not done something wrong. We can't say
you're bad if you don't have a criminal charge. Tectone needs
that to be true, right? Dr. Disrespect later went on to clarify
that nothing illegal happened and the cop Yeah, actually that's
the whole thing, isn't it? He he doesn't have a criminal charge.
So he's trying to drive home he's trying to reinforce the point
that if you don't have a criminal charge you actually didn't
really do anything wrong. You're actually totally fine.
Okay. I see why he's got a he certainly started with an ambitious
conversations were leading into the
Now what is leading into inappropriate conversation with a minor
mean? Does that mean that he was
slightly
or like ERPing with them? Does that mean that he said the word
too much? I don't know. But if these conversations were actually
you know s- with a minor well then yeah he should lose his entire
career. But if they were just him saying too many crude jokes
who knows. There is no proof of Dr. Disrespect ever doing anything
wrong whatsoever. The Twitch DMs were locked up and they were
never shown and that was Oh boy. Dude, we're back to it.
we're in a we're in a trouble or sorry, we're in trouble.
Now, we're going to have to trust like reporters who took statements
from people, right?
There's no proof. There's just no proof that Dr. Disrespect did
anything wrong.
It's like, well,
I'm going to tell you from my perspective, when basically people
are accusing him of trying to a minor and then he comes out and
goes, "Yeah, I sent really inappropriate conversations with that
minor."
I don't know why you would ever do that if it was anything like
if it was like you joked about having big balls or something
in this minor's
It's insane. It's a totally insane thing to think would happen.
Right? I feel like you only give that away because you think
the the DMs are going to leak or something. I'm positive that's
what happened back then. Dr.
got told by somebody that those DMs might come out and he freaked
out and he tried to get ahead of it and then they never came
out.
That's the only reason you confess to some [__] like
that. It was not by Dr. Disrespect, that was by Twitch himself.
He got involved in a lawsuit
with Twitch and Dr. Disrespect won that lawsuit and he didn't
win a little bit of money, $10,000,
$5,000,
$300.
Dr. Disrespect won into the 10 millions of dollars for this lawsuit
because a lot of Twitch current staff and ex-staff were in his
words defaming him. So, this is the big thing that I will never
understand on what really happened with Dr. Disrespect
because no one can really know
what happened because everything
was locked up. So, Dr. Disrespect actually went on stream. This
was like 24 hours ago and made this statement.
Oh, wait. I didn't know Dr. Disrespect made some statement on
this.
I didn't know he came out and did this.
What dude, he must have really fallen off if nobody was talking
about this or maybe it's just so outside of my Twitter algo,
I don't even know.
How the did I miss this that he made a statement on it? The thinking
that I'm some
or something. They're so stupid. Do that do do some actual thinking
with your brain. We won. WE WON. WE WALKED AWAY.
EIGHT FIGURES IN THE BACK POCKET. WE
I MEAN, the people that were calling Dr. Disrespect a
lost their lawsuit and had to pay 10
million dollars.
What? Huh?
I think wasn't Twitch just saying you violated some morality
clause or some I thought that's what Twitch Twitch clearly tried
to get out of whatever contract they signed with him, right?
So my remembrance how I remember this is basically he signed
a huge contract with Twitch. People have said it seemed like
he leveraged a fake offer to get Twitch to go really high and
then they couldn't prove that. So I think they went and used
these DMs as a pretext for getting rid of him, I thought.
That basically it's like oh well, morally you you've like violated
a morality clause here and we're letting you go. And then I'd
have to see what the actual settlement was, but I don't know
if we have anything from the
Now I have to go back and review all of this stuff. What do we
have? And then Mixer went down and they no longer needed the
bigger contract, sure. But I'm trying to think of like I think
basically they they got him on some ticky-tack [__]
for getting out of the contract and the judge found that it was
ticky-tack. It was like total bull actually. Like as much as
it was bad actions, it wasn't something that break the contract
over. I'm guessing, but here's the thing, it could easily have
come down to, well, he didn't do that in public. That's like
some private [__] that you would ever have known
about.
Like you you had to go and look through DMs, like his Twitch
DMs or whatever, to find that stuff, and that would never have
been public. You can't file a fire him for a private or sorry,
a public morality clause when it was private actions.
Like there's so many different little things that could have
happened here that it just makes it so Twitch broke a law contract-wise.
Not that he Not that what he did wasn't bad, not that he wasn't
trying to [__] a minor. Literally, nothing there,
right?
There's There's nothing like that. I don't know why we'd make
that up. >> This is not But this is another example, yet
again, of I won a court case, so I'm not guilty of a thing that
I obviously
Right? Everybody is mad about the actual morally bad thing you
did, and you're like, well, I won a court case that's sort of
relate that's sort of related to it, right? Like, okay.
But you still did the thing. Yeah, but like I won a court case.
They Okay, I don't care. We were all mad about the thing you
did, not about whether or not you had to pay money for it, whether
or not you got paid money for it.
a person-to-person
civil case. This is not a small claims court thing. This is one
man who went up against
an entire corporation,
AN ENTIRE BUSINESS,
AND beat them,
and won a eight-
FIGURE LAWSUIT. OKAY.
Trust me, I respect the aura it takes to try to [__]
a minor on Twitch's platform. They fire you and you go, ah, you're
going to pay out the rest of my contract anyway, and then you
do get paid out. I respect some amount of aura that that it that
it takes to do that, okay? I respect it a little bit, but I don't
respect trying to [__] a minor, okay? That's weird.
This is that is not a common occurrence. Businesses, corporations
can crush you because they can financially
drain you. Yet Doc
Yeah, but there's a limit to This happens to regular people.
Dr. Disrespect was already a millionaire. He already had all
the money to carry this lawsuit through. I'm guessing, depending
on how egregious the violation was on Twitch's part, I'm guessing
he could have got it done on um not on commission, what do they
call it? Whatever, not not spec or whatever, but there's a there's
a phrase for lawyers when they'll take just a percentage of the
winnings. I'm guessing like with how bad the contract violation
could have been contingency, yes, contingency. They could have
just taken it on contingency.
it These are such bad points. There's You can just tell Techtone
really really really needs
Dr. Disrespect to be okay, too. Dr. Disrespect won. I feel I
feel like somebody got in this argument with them on Twitter.
Like he was he was arguing on an alt on Twitter about how Techtone
was innocent and somebody was probably like, oh, well, Dr. Disrespect
won his court case or something. He didn't get a criminal charge.
He's still a And so Techtone felt the need to go and make a video
about it, okay? financially
laid out. drain you. Yet Dr. Disrespect won. 10
That was just crazy. The lowest number possible that he could
have won is 10
But he didn't win 10 million extra dollars. He just got what
was owed to
He Like winning the court case
No, the court case No, I actually, now that I think about it,
Mira Ariana, there was no winning. I think what happened was
they did decide to just not There was no fault on either side
and they just agreed to uphold the contract. That's what the
court case was, right? They broke the contract
and they settled neither side admitting fault and they just decided
to honor the contract, the original contract. So, it's not like
he won extra money. They settled, they paid him out his his contract,
and they decided not to talk about it anymore. That's what it
was. in dollars.
That's the minimum.
It could be a max of 90 MILLION. BEATING A CORPORATION, that's
a big deal. I want to replay this with that context in mind.
They're so >> stupid. Do that Do Do some actual thinking
with your brain. We won. Yeah. >> WE WON. WE WALKED AWAY
EIGHT FIGURES IN THE BACK POCKET. WE DID. WE'RE NOT IN JAIL.
WE'RE NOT IN PRISON. >> YEAH. On a what back in 2016
where anybody anybody can message anybody at any time. Yep. >> Anybody.
That means someone can reach out to the two-time and [__]
insult them or do whatever. I'm sorry. I responded in a inappropriate
joking way to somebody that [__] reached out to me
and just shut the [__] up, man. This whole industry
is so It's such a [__] It's a fest. It's a bunch
of fake It's a bunch of fakes and phonies everywhere, man. The
thing is is that I think he has a very good point. I do. I have
been someone who's approached the Dr. Disrespect situation with
a lot of
because
I'm not going to lie, I was biased. Dr. Disrespect was one of
the first streamers that I ever streamed stream snipe. I just
wanted to declare my biases. But Yeah, the Dr. Disrespect stuff
never went to court. They settled it entirely in like pre-trial
or like out of court arbitration. So, no Neither side admitted
wrongdoing and they just paid out the rest of his contract and
kept him banned. He wanted to be allowed back on the platform,
by the way. That was what was supposed to be a win for him. I
think he wanted to go back on
Didn't happen. >> But I'm not quick to call people over
nothing. I I know that's the trend that a lot of content creators
do. The moment there's any type of scent in the air or blood
in the water, everybody's so quick to call you. But until I see
what a criminal investigation says,
I'm really not going to damn someone, to be completely honest.
>> Told you. That's where he was obviously going the entire
time.
Where he was obviously going the whole time. Guys, you need a
criminal charge. Without a criminal charge, you've done nothing
wrong. All bad behavior is criminal behavior. No non-criminal
behavior is bad behavior. Right. Now, will I take participation
in the jokes?
For example, did I make some Dr. Disrespect jokes? Absolutely.
I even made some LikaRai jokes. You know, a couple of notepad
jokes. Absolutely. I got you, Jimmerly. We'll put it on screen,
okay? But right now, do I believe that LikaRai or Dr. Disrespect
are p- No, I don't. And do you want to know why? Because if they
were, they'd be in jail. If they were, they'd be in prison. Right
now, until I see hard evidence and hard proof, I'm just not going
to do that. And to be honest, God, we need another Tectone Destiny
collab. They're on the same page, okay? They're the They're the
same r- right now. Listen, I need Tectone needs that video of
Dr. Disrespect that minor, okay? Nothing else is going to convince
him, all right? Give him the video of of Dr. Disrespect that
little kid, or he will never call Dr. Disrespect a p- okay? Dr.
Disrespect won the lawsuit against a corporation
and won adding million 10 million dollars. I just don't believe
that this guy's a p- I don't.
At worst, he's a cheater. You can call him a cheater. He admitted
to being a cheater. But, I've seen no proof that Dr. Disrespect
has children before. I have never seen this But, that's not the
claim. The claim is he tried to.
I have not seen that at all. I have never seen any proof of that
whatsoever.
I mean, so winning a $10 million lawsuit speaks volumes. There
was also a post put out. Did the child safety team get involved
with Dr. Disrespect? Yes. According to a former Twitch Trust
and Safety employees who spoke to Rolling Stone, Dr. Disrespect
was reported to the National Center for Missing and Exploited
Children the day of his ban in compliance with federal law. The
source stated they did not know if any investigation resulted
from the report. However, Twitch's own internal investigation
concluded that the messages were not
or in violation of child exploitation federal law. No criminal
charges were filed. Dr. Disrespect has denied any wrongdoing
claiming the messages Wait, this seems a little off to me. Because
is the So, what I recall the claim to be was that he basically
had some slightly inappropriate messages.
And then that he basically had tried to arrange meeting with
the person at TwitchCon. But, that it was like very
that he intended to have something happen, okay?
I Did he deny that? I don't know if he denied that. We'll see.
We'll see. I'm sure I'll I'm sure I'll be able to find some like
some better explanations of this stuff to be honest. >> and
that the recipient was over the age of consent. So, no
So, I'm not going to lie, man.
I don't know why people are still calling this man a Maybe other
I mean, I'll be real. I don't think anything else is going to
happen. I mean, if if the messages were researched, if he was
already investigated into, if no wrongdoing was found, if the
police were involved, no wrongdoing was found. If he won a lawsuit,
not a civil lawsuit, A CRIMINAL LAWSUIT WITH a business
FOR 10 MILLION DOLLARS
NOT TO cover lawyer fees, but to cover the damages done to his
name. I'm sorry.
I I cannot subscribe to people calling him a pedo.
it seems like
we go to the Rolling Stone article.
I'm I'm pretty sure what we're going to find is that he repeatedly
had inappropriate messages with this minor, that he continued
to talk to them after he was informed that they were a minor.
so minor. So, three sources confirmed to Bloomberg that Beam
had been kicked off the site for sending direct messages to a
minor that included graphic details. Two of those sources also
confirmed that Beam had asked her about her plans for the upcoming
TwitchCon. Okay. Oh, here we go.
So, a former Twitter Trust and Safety employee who worked for
the platform at the time Beam was banned and has direct knowledge
of the matter confirmed to Rolling Stone that Beam continued
to send graphic messages to a minor he knew to be underage. So,
he had already gotten her age in the conversation.
I recall that Dr. Disrespect was made aware by the individual
that they were underage during the conversation, after which
he indicated that this was no problem and continued on.
>> Real Jake Lang-esque
behavior, okay? Him and Jake Lang, same guy. I just Yeah, I don't
I I straight-up don't get
I I don't. I just can't, man. It's
it's crazy. Okay. So, I think what Tectone's trying to get at
here is he doesn't believe any of this reporting. He believes
this reporting is all lies,
Which is I don't know, pretty crazy. I will say
like I guess, how would you how How you go about defending yourself
here?
Like clearly Dr. Disrespect thinks some of these things are lies,
right? Again, I think it comes down to like, "Hey,
I am going to sue you guys for libel. This is These are lies."
Right? And that should be very like fruitful for him to do to
try to get his reputation try to salvage his
But here's this article standing
years later. Okay. Because I don't think he is one.
And then that's crazy, man. That's a wild allegation. I mean,
yeah, I don't know how people are still calling this guy a in
when he won the lawsuit and the investigation found no wrongdoing.
That's not what anyone said.
That's not what anyone said. How does he not I This is like basically
my job now is trying to figure out if somebody is
performing re or actually re
Right? That he's just He's sitting here like, "Well, listen.
There's no wrongdoing. There's no nothing illegal. There's no
wrongdoing." Does Teckton really think that? No, he definitely
doesn't really think that. He definitely would have been on some
cancel trains. Remember when he cried? What did Rich do that
was illegal? Where was the proof that Rich did anything illegal,
buddy? When you went on stream and blubbered and cried about
how much he betrayed you and all of your friends, little bi
This guy, by the way, we stand we stand with despite the fact
that Rich Campbell is in a group of utter degenerates, okay?
We stand with Rich Campbell, okay? We love Rich Campbell here.
Rich Campbell Nobody's handled allegations better than Rich Campbell,
okay? We love Rich Campbell That's just the way it is. And Asmongold
and Teckton tried to sell Rich Campbell down the river, and I
don't know I hope I hope one day when that entire OTK empire
falls, when those when those guys all have their careers destroyed,
I hope it's Rich Campbell who spent the past 2 years concocting
a scheme to make it happen, okay?
I hope so cuz they [__] him over.
That's just my opinion. So, you know, as of right now
as of what are we?
March 13th, 2026,
I think Dr. Disrespect got [__] over, but I will
be real. If he never said that did the conversations lean to
the inappropriate side? Yes.
I feel like if he did not say that he would still be on top.
And he still kind of is.
That's what I said at the time. When that came out, I was like,
"Dude, this is such an unforced error. All you had to do is just
not talk."
You could just say it's false. You could just say it's wrong.
You basically just could deny.
It was such an insane unforced error for no reason. I was like,
"Dude, you could have gotten away with this completely. I can't
believe you did this to yourself." here today.
Because he never clarified what that meant. Very interesting.
We'll see if there's any other follow-ups. I know a lot of other
streamers are terrified to talk about this right now, but as
far as I'm concerned, I don't think Dr.
And that's because the proven evidence
and the investigations
and the criminal court charges all proved to the fact that he
was innocent in that regard. Bye. No, they don't.
Dude, I mean, you could say you don't believe he's guilty of
a child, but nobody has ever made that allegation, actually.
So, I don't know why you would do that unless you just want to
sweep for somebody who had inappropriate conversations with a
minor, knowing they were a minor. opinion. Let me know what y'all
think. The Dr. Disrespect situation is crazy.
He shouldn't be talking to anyone under
In that report, it also said the person he was talking to was
above the age of
So Dude, Tectone, listen. I would respect Tectone if he was just
if he just came out and was like, "Listen. That guy was going
to TwitchCon in
Age of consent was 16. I'm totally down with Dr. Disrespect [__]
16-year-old in Europe. Let's go. If he said I would have some
respect for him. Like just say it. Just say I'm totally fine
with guys with Twitch streamers arranging to [__]
a 16-year-old when they go to Twitch Con Europe. Right? Just
say that [__] man. I'll be real. And I'm going to
say this one more time because people keep on chiming in.
The person was above the age of consent.
It was confirmed that it was not
He won That's not true. His Whoa, hold on. It wasn't under California
law, likely. lawsuit against a multi-million
dollar company Twitch with the backing of Amazon as a sole individual.
This person is dumb. I don't know what else people want him to
do to prove his innocence, but in this regard, I think he got
[__] over. That's my opinion. What else do you want
me to say? Let me know what you think. Okay. Well, I think Tectone's
an obvious
Very cool.
Apparently, I don't think this has really blown up yet. A couple
people are commenting, okay? What do I have I think I've got
a Forsen comment. Hold on. This is something that is not a common
occurrence. Or I I feel like I'm going to get so baited
into Forsen just not speaking for the entire clip and then a
soundboard happening and then he like laughs. Okay, he's going
to get like a donation and he's going to laugh and it's not going
to be him saying a single word while Tectone speaks. I feel like
that's almost certainly what's happening here. me. Businesses,
corporations,
can
Is he
uh is he taking him for his word and character? Oh. Is this guy
There's no way Twitch paid him
10 plus million. This guy is absolutely
What the No, I do I do actually believe that
But it it's not like a 10 like Tectone's kind of implying it's
a wrongdoing that they paid over, right? I do believe it was
just you can't break this contract the way you did. I think that's
all it was. rush you because they can
drain you. Wait until he hears about his billion-dollar NDAs
that he's signing every other weekend.
It'll blow his mind. Dr. Disrespect won
That was just crazy. It was likely the contract amount, but we
don't know. No, I think that's explicitly like what he was suing
for was to get his contract money back.
Like that's explicitly what he said when he did it. He was trying
to
sue Twitch over his 2020 permanent ban and the loss of his exclusivity
But actually, there is technically no proof whatsoever. In fact,
if you want to talk about it this way, there is absolutely no
proof what so whatsoever that he was paid a dime.
There's literally zero proof of that.
There's no public filing of the settlement. There's not There's
nothing. Wasn't done in open court. He could just be lying. He
could have lost every element to that case. They could have just
said, "Okay, we'll agree to go our separate ways and we won't
publish this and we'll just be fine."
Yeah, that's There's just no evidence in either direction. So,
Teccy don't shouldn't believe his word on this at And Wow.
Okay, hold on. Apparently, Teccy don't also didn't like the way
his community respond was responding to him and he talked about
it on a stream today. I got to pull this up. Yeah, Forsen versus
Teccy don't. This is something that I never thought I would have
to say in my entire life, but I would actually love to see this.
So So, Forsen
Forsen of all people called me out. I am curious why. Um a lot
of people are not liking my take on the Dr. Disrespect situation
and I'm totally okay with that. I'm cool with that. I don't care.
I'm I'm curious to hear what his criticism of what I said is.
Let's Let's hear it real quick. Eight. I just I I don't know
how Tectone does anything. I don't know how Tectone comes back
from this. Why do you believe that like anything about the settlement?
Like I believe it cuz it seemed like it all fit. But now that
Forsen,
genius philosopher that he is, the modern-day Diogenes that he
is, just pointed out that really there is not there's literally
no reason to believe that even.
Like nothing. Like it could be zero he could have gotten zero
dollars.
THANK YOUR LAWSUIT. [screaming] >> YEP. THIS IS something
that is not a common occurrence. Businesses, corporations
can Facts. Is he
uh is he taking him for his word and character? Yeah, because
you couldn't lie about that. Why? Why couldn't you lie about
that?
Wait, why couldn't you lie about that? What? That would be such
an easily disprovable lie that would completely obliterate all
narratives against Dr. Disrespect. Yeah.
If someone says a very easily disprovable lie, a very easily
disprovable lie that he has been saying
I mean, if it's an easily disprovable lie, you can prove it's
true, right?
So then, prove it's true, right? If you know it's not a lie,
it would be easily disprovable. Who's I don't know who's going
to disprove it. I guess Twitch? I don't know why they would bother
coming out and talking about it. For nearly 4 months, yes.
I absolutely would. Because if at any point Twitch were to say,
"By the way, that didn't happen."
Everything involving Dr. Disrespect would be completely obliterated.
Is this guy [__] [__] or what? There's
no way Twitch paid him
10 plus million. This guy is absolutely
What the [__]
Why is there absolutely no way if it was already proven by literal
fact that they agreed to a settlement? Oh, hold on. With the
circumstances that settlement? Like under an NDA? [laughter]
Wait, also I I do believe the general circumstances around that
settlement were under NDA as well, which is why he said he didn't
speak about any of this for so long. Um dude, this is all publicly
available data. It show it.
Dude, he's actually digging himself such a hole over nothing.
He just decided he's going to go and defend Dr. Disrespect and
now he's saying it's obviously it's just publicly verifiable
data that he got a big settlement from them. Guys, what the [__]
are you saying? Um I actually love Forsen and I have no interest
in having any beef with this guy whatsoever,
but the reality is everything that is currently being said is
publicly available data.
So I don't I don't know what this guy thinks that I'm wrong about.
Dude, I can already see how this is going to go. He's going to
say this [__] and then somebody some up in his chat
is going to be like, wait, what do you mean? And they're going
to lose it and he's going to end up getting one guy right? That
has to be how this goes. But I I can I can fully explain it.
Um yeah, I mean since it was settled there was really no way
to tell the actual number.
Okay, so I can explain to you everything that had happened. Okay,
hope hope this makes sense. He's arguing that Doc is constantly
playing a character. Well, I guess that means if every single
time Dr. Disrespect talks we should just consider it an absolute
[__] Like guys, once again, I think Doc is an absolute
piece of [__] I mean he cheated on his wife, okay?
That that's that's that's beyond [__] Right? Like
legit, it's beyond [__] But like I'm underneath the
impression that the truth already makes the Doc look bad enough,
why make up other lies, right? Let's just at least keep what
is actually provable
what we go off of and not just go over what we think it happened.
It's very I actually I don't know if you guys are Cheating's
not okay. Cheating is dog [__] You're a dog [__]
human being if you cheat. You are Everybody who copes about cheating
is just somebody who would cheat. You're just You're just a human
being for cheating. You're just giving in to your impulses. And
everybody who defends it is something that like naturally
I've no respect for them. Just Just admit you were piece of [__]
Just admit you were piece of [__] okay? Don't do
that [__] in my chat, okay? It's [__]
It annoys the [__] out of me. Something happens all
the time. That means it's good. No, it doesn't.
Turkey Tom Yeah, when Turkey Tom did that it was [__]
When everybody does it, it's [__] Okay? It's just
always [__] They'd crush you because they can
Yeah. drain you. >> Yeah. Yeah. Wait until he hears about
his billion-dollar NDAs
that he's signing every other weekend.
It'll blow his mind. Dr. billion-dollar
NDAs.
Dr. Disrespect one, 10 I got no idea what Force is talking about
there, to be honest with you. >> 10 billion-dollar
>> Hold on. Except for the fact that clearly Dr. Disrespect
in like all of the IRL situations I've seen him in, is trying
to hit on some woman or trying to [__] some woman.
Like it It's probably true that he does like the gay and he tries
to frown on his marriage, I'm
But yeah, I've I've got no idea of the specifics. I'm guessing
a lot of times with streamers and that's probably why Force knows
some [__] All right. Oh, I see. Billion-dollar NDAs.
I see. Oh, I
Is that like a It's probably even a reference. I'm guessing that's
actually a reference to something he said.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's go Let's go look up This is Wait. >> Is
Dr. Disre
Dude, I'm It's coming back to me the Dr. Disrespects out. That's
where the gripping it meme comes from, right?
Is it Isn't that literally like the phrase that that person was
using in DMs with Dr. Disrespect? Right? respect signing signing
billion-dollar
Are there
any confirmations?
I assume that was like So, what Force is saying is in character,
he he bigs up everything. Like He's talks about billion-dollar
NDAs. I assume I know Dr. Disrespect has NDAs. I just assumed
he was exaggerating.
of this. I I've never Tectone not seeing through the character
either time >> ever heard of any billion dollar NDAs.
No, there are no credible confirmations that Dr. Disrespect Guy
Beahm has signed a billion dollar NDA. This appears to be an
exaggeration or meme level rumor circulating in game >> Dude,
Grog immediately picks up what it actually is. Grog just infers
naturally what it is. Dude, no way. Oh, Tectone's
right now. Dude, oh, [laughter] that's >> gaming streaming
communities often got a history of big deal settlements and cryptic
references NDAs. Okay, so let me get this right. So, I'm
because every single Okay, so you need to understand this.
>> I should probably make this a video, but due to my previous
uh respect for Forsen's content. I used to be a huge Forsen viewer
back when he played PUBG and Hearthstone. I wish he [laughter]
finished that thought. Let me get Let me get this right. I'm
because And then he was about to say the exact reasons he he
stopped I think he had some idea that he's a little off here,
so he stopped cuz that would have been an awesome clip. I
First of all, I'm not going to make this a video
out of respect to Forsen.
Yeah, so that's a meme. The billion dollar NDAs don't exist.
Second of all, right? Every single contract that is long term
have this thing called right to terminate.
And right to terminate means that if you
your contract, if there was a breach of contract, and Guy Beahm
Dr. Disrespect was signed on to a eight figure deal with Twitch,
right? If that contract was breached, they had the right to terminate
at any time, and they
And he was paid out eight figures.
They had the right to terminate at any time and they couldn't?
What? So that What am I I'm just going to I'm just going to let
it play through. He just said something that was I think by the
little words he said again, but >> That's all I'm saying
is that if you
if you look at the publicly verifiable
there's a lot of things that you can [__] on Doc
for, absolutely.
Right? But I don't like the culture of assuming other things
that did not happen. Right? So I'm just trying to keep everything
down to the facts. Once again, I'm not saying this as a current
huge fan of Dr. Disrespect. The guy cheated on his wife.
But what I am saying is Dr. Disrespect got paid out eight figures
when they could have and should have had the right
to terminate the contract, but they didn't and it was paid out.
That's insane and I feel like way too many people are overlooking
that. But yeah.
Yeah. And the other thing is you can't end So apparently the
way this goes is somebody says go watch the WestGee video on
this and then he watches the WestGee video and the I I do believe
he's going to realize how stupid he is for arguing this, okay?
NDA a crime.
So I don't know what Forsen is saying that Dr. Disrespect is
being signed or is signing billion-dollar NDAs, but to also imply
that Dr. Disrespect is putting NDAs on people for illegal
That's legally not a I think Forsen's probably referring to,
now that I think about it, it's he's probably referring to Doc
talking about the NDA with Twitch and why he couldn't talk about
the settlement with Twitch, right? Did everybody just forget
that this whole like this weird cloud hung around Dr. Disrespect
for years before he got any clarity, that nobody would say why
he was banned, that they basically just ignored the question
for years and years and years.
I People just forgot that. Like a year after the whole Dr. Disrespect
drama happened, everyone forgot that there was like years of
just no
nobody talking about what happened there
thing that you can do.
So, I I do find it crazy that
so many people are voicing opinions that are publicly verifiable
false.
And they have the audacity to call me That's what's insane. So,
No, you mean 10 figures? No, Forbes says the exact number was
a billion-dollar
That's what he said. Yeah, I think he got NDA. The real reason
he got banned that makes Twitch look bad, not Doc. Honestly,
I have no idea. No, I I think
See, I understand that that's a way you could look at it in a
really naive way. I do think there's a lower burden of proof
in his civil hearing, like in his thing, than what there would
have been for like Dr. Disrespect to win something where he's
like actually got a tort. So, it's like different. But sure,
if he's just going to go with, well, he won the lawsuit, that
means he's innocent.
You want to flip that and just do the opposite and say, well,
you lost yours, so it means you're guilty.
I You would think, given how slow the the gears move up here,
he would want to avoid that, but I don't know. Maybe he's just
too dumb to even think of that, okay? People calling the schizophrenic
guy is insane. Well, idea, and nor do I have any It's TechRax
one of those guys. It's just obvious he's like running entirely
on tone, right? He's just There's no real arguments he's making,
or he's not making any significant argument. He's not making
any like defensible argument. He's just doing the tone thing.
I can't believe how much of the internet is just that, and yet
I can somehow.
Like Trump should be your first indication that all that matters
is tone. You just say you won
millions believe you. It's really It's particularly [__]
up
most people are the kind of person who would like believe Trump
saying
and then all the people who like see that is bad and don't want
to do that are competing for like a tiny tiny fraction of the
population for all the viewership online. It's like dude, it's
actually [__] up. It's sort of It It kind of makes
me understand a little bit how someone like Candace Owens just
Well, Candace was always a grifter. Who's somebody who like dipped
into it who just decided they're going to go make money. I'd
almost understand it a little bit, okay?
You almost You almost start to get it. ban that makes Twitch
look bad, not Doc. Honestly, I have no idea and nor do I have
any room to where I want to speculate. I just like laying out
the publicly verifiable facts
before we assume all this [__] because assuming is
how the next your favorite content creator is going to lose his
career over [__] that he didn't do. I have no desire
to crash out over forcing. I'm not even making this a [__]
YouTube video. Right? And this was another LSF hate thread that
I got for no reason. I apologize that I know these things more
than you do, but I don't really know why you want to hold that
against me. LSF hate thread? No, not an LSF hate thread. We'll
talk out of the ass. And once again, there's a chance that I'm
wrong. Maybe some of the information I saw was
But as far as I'm concerned and as far as I'm aware,
I don't believe
that I was off.
Now, I was
I was
called out by another guy. I was called out by another guy.
And this one I would love to react to. Everybody's allowed to
[__] on Dr. Disrespect for cheating on his wife.
That's publicly verifiable.
It is. Um but everything else, there's kind of been a big gray
area on what is true and what's not. So, I'm here to just keep
things factual. That's what I'd like to do. I'd like to keep
things factual. I don't Just keep it keep it to the facts. Let's
keep it to the facts, guys.
Just keep it to the publicly verifiable data, as he says. >> care
what you think about these people, but I'd rather at least tell
you. Now, let's get into WestJett's reaction, cuz I am curious
what he thought about all this [__] So, let's get
right into it. Massive day for the unemployed. Dr. Disrespect
is having beef with everybody, and it's kind of funny. >> Like,
DON'T GET ME WRONG, BRO. I THINK THE JOKES ARE HILARIOUS.
I do. I do. I just don't think the guy [__] kid.
I just don't think that. All right, let's keep going here. A
good joke of a human. Don't cheat on your wife again, you [__]
loser. And I'm not going to lie, Nick Mercs absolutely, you know,
hey, Dr. Disrespect absolutely
got called the [__] out for that. And the guy can
be up
Don't think that I'm pretty sure I recognize that Nick Mercs
callout. That wasn't because of the chief the cheating, right?
That was Nick Mercs burning him for having some conversations
with a minor. said what Nick Mercs said, but he can't say that
he's wrong. Bro did cheat on his wife, and to BE HONEST, THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO MOVE ON FROM. THAT MIGHT MAKE YOU
UPSET, and it's great that they're still together for the sake
of the kid, but that's not something that he's going to be able
to move on from. Let's keep going here. Dr. Disrespect wannabe.
I don't know if that's true. There was actually a lot of Dr.
Disrespect wannabes, but then the guy died in prison who could
identify THEM ALL. NOW, LET'S
AND THEN HE GOT DUDE, DUDE, that's the thing of messing with
someone who has true charisma, man. They will clown the [__]
out of you. It's the same with WestJett, right? Love WestJett,
horrified of the guy, cuz the guy's jokes, man, they will they
will eat you knights.
I I had no idea
I had no idea that his like his I guess obsession with did not
just extend only to receiving, it also extended to giving, okay?
Also, he is glazing the worst people, the worst streamers, the
worst content >> You will live, buddy. They will eat you
>> That guy still talking after many years.
Oh my god. Forgot what happened to Dr. Disrespect? Well, let
me catch you back to speed. A Twitch employee alleged he was
talking to a minor and then he had the worst response possible,
which he edited like three times. >> I I I agree. I think
if Dr. Disrespect never put out this statement, I think he'd
be a lot better off. I think that's like the case for every single
I think that's the case for every single person who's ever confessed
to wrongdoing in their entire life. It basically just never helps
you, okay? Yes, confessions of wrongdoing, especially public
squares, are usually bad for your reputation.
I think Dr. Disrespect's biggest enemy was himself here. However,
I understand the pressure of the internet can lead you to [__]
up like this. And that's what sucks. But he he himself hard.
He himself hard with this statement. >> Dr. Disrespect
released another statement where he admitted to the claim of
talking to a minor through Twitch Whispers inappropriately. Were
there Twitch Whisper messages with an individual minor back in
2017? That answer is yes. Yeah, this was this was insane. From
all I've seen that the person was confirmed to be over the age
of consent. That's information that I think we found out in 2025.
So, I still have no idea what this means. Because the other thing
is, well, where were they from? Were they above 18? I love I
love the finer like defense, okay?
And by the way, you could just make this argument. If you truly
believe it, just make the argument outright. Don't Don't tiptoe
around it, right? Yeah, they're a minor, but they're a minor.
And I want to minors is what Tectone should say, okay? So, I'm
going to defend the guys who try minors. That's That's your argument,
Tectone. Just own it. Just own it. Because it might have been
the age because I believe the age of consent in Alabama is 16.
SO, WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE AGE of this person. We still don't
know what inappropriate means. There's a lot of speculation,
and it sucks.
I wish things like this Just fill in the age. Just fill in the
age and tell me when you think it's gross. Let's play that game.
At what age does Dr. Disrespect become a bad person?
17? Clearly not. Clearly not cuz you're implying this could be
fine. 16?
I mean, I I'd say so, but I don't know what Tectone would say.
15, Tectone? What if it was in Iceland?
And 15 was on the table, would that be
I need Tectone to do the Mr. Girl game of which strip club he
would pick, okay? What age are you willing to let your friends
go down to where you're still comfortable with it?
Come on. This were clear-cut, but they're not. >> Were there
real intentions behind these messages? No. These were casual
mutual
>> There are interstate commerce laws that that apply to
this stuff like this. It's why you can't send nudes as well.
Patience that sometimes are leaning too much on the direction
of being inappropriate, but nothing more. Which is a crazy thing
to say. Like >> Absolutely. if any of you have watched
To Catch a Predator, you'll recognize that tactic that that little
maneuver right there because that's something that was pretty
frequent on that show when a Now, the other thing is with Moist
Critical, I I really don't give a [__] about his
opinion on anything cuz all he does is go on to Reddit and read
Twitter comments and then just regurgitate whatever the popular
opinion is. So like Where did you get this opinion of Moist Critical
by the way?
From people who mock people who go on Reddit and get all the
popular comments and then come up with the least offensive opinion.
From like the next tier of Moist
Moist Critical really saying something doesn't really add anything
at all. He just takes other people's opinions and claims them
as his own. So I don't really care. But uh this thing did hit
mainstream and that's important about Charlie is he'll only cover
the things that are mainstream and that's where it becomes a
big deal. It's like oh, this is the popular thing to talk about
because that's what Charlie does. Predator went down and talked
with Chris Moist is a fence sitter? I don't even think Moist
is a fence sitter. I think he's kind of just like a drone that's
incapable of forming his own opinions. So he just Now this guy
is just
Dude, every every person that I cover feels like it it does feel
like they watch the criticisms and then they Who is he skin walking
here? This is very funny. Like it's actual skin walking.
That's what it is. It's crazy.
Why is he got to talk like me?
regurgitates whatever the popular one is. Tension, a lot of them
Once again, I'm saying this as someone who likes
But sometimes saying the hard truth and that's going to seem
like talk and sure it is. But my problem is is that when that
is your character so much, it's it's it's it's I guess if that
upsets you then maybe don't act like that. Because that is entirely
a proper summary of how he acts. You know what I'm saying? And
it sucks. It's like I enjoy his content. I I like when he makes
the Moist Meter. Um but yeah, it is what it is. said that same
thing pretty much. MAYBE DON'T DO THAT. TRUE. >> kids Yo,
yo, yo, slow down. Don't say that. You know I watched that clip
of that stupid phony Nickmercs. [snorts] We got them all huffing
and puffing over The go to go to him screaming and sh What a
phony that that
And I'm going to continue to call his ass out all the time, champs.
Just to remind you Dude, this music is so fitting cuz the thing
is and this is what actually is horrible. You know, Dr. Disrespect
and Nick Mercs like used to really [__] with each
other and I can tell that Doc used to consider this guy a friend.
Man, you can He's hurt, bro. He's hurt. But hey, man, if if you
don't want to get hurt by your own homies, then don't cheat on
your wife. And it SURE WOULD BE NICE IT'S so funny that he thinks
that Nick Mercs' statement was because Doc cheated on his wife.
I don't know, are you Nick Mercs stood by him through that? Nick
Mercs was totally down to still collab with him through that.
Come on, >> If other people got [__] on, would
they cheat on their significant others? BUT FOR SOME REASON,
EVERYBODY OVERLOOKS IT IF THE WOMAN CHEATS ON THE MAN. AND I
DON'T GET IT. IT'S
CRAZY. WELL, WHERE DOES THAT HAPPEN?
BRO, I've been on the incel part of the internet for quite a
while. I'm pretty sure there's whole like there's whole meme
genres that are built out of guys getting [__] over
by evil, conniving
duplicitous women, okay?
Like Like what are we talk What culture What internet culture
is he a part of? Name the example. Uh what would be a good example?
Uh Kaede?
Dude, Kaede is like not even confirmed cheating. Bro, people
are in on Kaede right now. That's an That's an example from the
past couple weeks. Dude, weren't people Oh, no, no, I don't know
about that one. I was going to say, weren't people in on Pokimane
for the same thing when they thought that the one guy cheated
on her, but I don't think that's the same thing. I wasn't around
watching streams back then. But obviously, people do care about
the woman cheating. They do. CUZ LIKE I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, BRO.
When Shmee reviews wife
to his best friend. Oh, [laughter] that's a unique thing though.
How are you going to use Chippy reviews as the example? We all
get it with Chippy reviews, okay?
We all get it in that case.
Even then, dude, that
That I even felt some empathy until you like started really leaning
into the victimization, like the self-victimization,
and then it just became funny, man.
Bro, when he's when he's like, "And then I went and tried to
talk to my boys because my best friend cheated with my with my
fiance. I went to try to talk to my boys, and they all wanted
to hang out with Mike, the guy who cheated on me." Or sorry,
my wife and the guy who cheated on me with her. Like, no. [__]
You get what I'm saying, okay? I'm saying that wrong. But basically,
they choose the they chose the bull, okay?
They all chose the bull.
HIS WHOLE FRIEND group did not give a [__] about
it at all.
That [__] was crazy.
THAT [__] WAS CRAZY.
THAT PEOPLE LIKE him exist in this industry. Two-faced, phony,
as fake as it can be, man. I really don't think Nick Merch is
two-faced at all. I just don't think he the people who cheat
on their wife, you know? I pretty sure that's all it is. Which
don't can cheat on your wife, then yeah. He's so hilariously
wrong about this entire thing. And bro took that as a challenge.
You want to say that in front of me? Shh. My bad. Oh, I'm 15,
>> I got a wife. Jesus.
I play Uh I really feel like Dr. Disrespect's best course of
action is to just roll it solo,
the ball, do his own thing, you know? I mean, he's still doing
great. He's got to not worry about this because he's got way
too much publicly verifiable baggage on him. You ain't that dumb
ass [__]
You got a problem with it? Then guess what? You got a problem
with it. And he's not even like that. So, tell him to quit [__]
acting with his little wig and his glasses, man. That's all he
does. He's a [__] actor and he act It's also insane
to call somebody two-faced when that two-faced guy, you know,
another chick while he was married. You know what I mean? Like
Dr. Disrespect should not be calling anybody two-faced. He really
shouldn't.
Cuz that's what actors do. All right? He puts his little [__]
thing Like it's not fun, but like Dr. Disrespect is going to
have to eat [__] forever. Or I mean, to be honest,
he could also just retire. What is going on here? Gimberlee,
thank you for the five gifted. Appreciate it, man. That gets
us another hour on the stream.
[__] go. Thank you very much. I appreciate it. Irons,
you know, lived the life with his wife and kid, you know?
I I never understand how people who have that much money, and
he's like a multi multi multi-million. I mean, the guy has confirmed
he has at least eight figures. You know what I mean? Like the
guy can do whatever the [__] he wants. Like [__]
what anybody else I love The best part about winning your salary
back from Twitch is technically you don't have to pay any of
that to the government, guys. Did you know that? That if they
try to [__] you over and take your money and then
you win it from them, actually the government doesn't get to
touch that. That's not even income anymore. So, it's definitely
just over 10 million, for sure, 100% guys, cuz you know, taxes
don't exist. As long as you win it from a corporation. says.
You know what I'm saying? Like [__] what anybody
says, bro. You got money. When you're in the $10 million range,
you can do whatever the [__] you want. >> that
every day and he talks around. He's been doing it for years.
Good for him. These guys are like 47 years old of being on the
internet, but uh what happened with burnt peanut? I'm curious.
Even though Hasan is cringe as hell, he said the funniest thing
about burnt peanut of like all time. >> Bro, this is this
is the number one number one streamer of Israel.
Israel's finest. Connecting a VTuber to Israel is actually insane.
Stop. This is >> Yeah, I don't get the Israeli plant burnt
peanut. I I don't get it. I think the guy is ridiculously funny.
Insane. Listen, if you have used DoorDash in the last couple
of years, okay.
Again, just no connection of reality on anything. Bro, ain't
nobody out here saying you can't be funny.
Like all of comedy is built on work, okay? We all know they could
be funny.
This is one of the things they don't suck at. And that I'm some
or something. They're so
Do that Do Do some actual thinking with your brain. We won. WE
WON. WE WALKED
EIGHT FIGURES IN THE BACK POCKET.
WE DID. WE'RE NOT IN JAIL. WE'RE NOT IN PRISON. AND IN THE COURT
of law >> Yeah. a judge went into all the information.
Yeah. >> Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Getting hit with the oblivion NPC music by his best friend West.
You hate to see it, guys. You hate to see it. WE'RE NOT IN JAIL.
WE'RE NOT IN PRISON. AND IN THE court of law >> Yeah. a
judge went into all the information. Yeah. And he said that nothing
illegal happened. It's time to finish on Tech Donut. It actually
never went to court. It was settled. Wait. Yeah, no. It's settled
before court.
Right? I don't
>> This guy is so stupid. Uh it's so transparent.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. It was settled before court. So, like the
judge had to rule on it. No, I dude, I swear that's the next
place he's going to go. The judge had to rule on it. Nope. Nope,
that's not how civil agreements work. That's not how like some
civil settlement works. You only have to notify the judge that
the the like settlement happened to dismiss the case.
I don't think judges in civil cases are required to like arbitrate
most things.
I'll explain this in a second. I'll cuz I I actually I'm not
going to Okay, I'm not going to spoil this, but I actually had
a conversation with WestJett over this and I explained to him
what actually happened and we came to a mutual agreement. So,
I'm going to make that conversation public right after this.
Back in 2016
where anybody anybody can message anybody at any time. Yeah,
but nobody's forcing you to respond to anybody anyway. I'm sorry.
I responded in a in a >> I'll respond in full at the end
of the >> appropriate joking way to somebody that reached
out to me and It's just shut the [__] up, man. He
got involved in a lawsuit with Twitch and Dr. DisRespect won
that lawsuit. >> Yeah, dog, you got to stop smoking the
Genshin pack. They never went to court, they never saw a judge.
Where are you getting this info? If he won I'll explain Guys,
guys, listen, I talked to and we we agreed on something and then
WestJett just [__] hits him again. Oh, boy. I don't
know if Did Tecto not expect this? A lawsuit
Not a civil lawsuit, a criminal lawsuit with a business
FOR 10 MILLION DOLLARS. WAIT, DID I MISS HIM say
Did I miss him say that when I watched the original video? A
lawsuit
Not a civil lawsuit, a criminal lawsuit
A criminal I missed him say that during the video.
Obviously, he was saying so many things I must have paused in
the middle of this or something.
A civil
a criminal lawsuit, guys. You know, you know when you file a
criminal tort with your lawyers and you go to a criminal tort?
I'm going to sue you in criminal court.
That's definitely how that works. It definitely doesn't go through
the government. The government isn't the one who sits on that
stuff.
Yeah. Wow. Wow.
With a business
FOR 10 MILLION DOLLARS. >> YEAH. SOMEBODY needs to check
TechTard's sources. Sources? Genshin Impact. That's so good,
bro. That That'll That'll
That's not even funny. That's literally not even funny. I There's
ways you could have made that funny. That's literally not even
funny. So, he's fake laughing and still sucking up to this guy.
Okay? never not be funny. Because where is he getting this stuff,
man? Do I believe that Lacari or Dr. Disrespect are files? No,
I don't. And do you want to know why? Because if they were, they'd
be in jail. Not even EDP is in jail, bro. What are you saying?
Like [laughter] Didn't think of the EDP example, dude. Oh my
god. Oh, explain that one as well. Hardy was pretty bad, dude.
I'm going to lie. He won his lawsuit against a multi- I misspoke.
He won his settlement. Let me I misspoke. He million-dollar company
Twitch with the backing of Amazon as a sole individual. Yeah.
And there literally nobody won. Nobody admitted fault in the
situation. It's literally a mutually agreed upon
settlement. Twitch with the backing of Amazon as a sole Well,
hold on. If you If you had a settlement from somebody, they admitted
wrongdoing. I do think you could say that's a win. But explicitly,
neither side admitted fault. sole individual. He didn't even
win. It was just settled, bro. What are we saying here? Did the
child safety team get involved with Dr. Disrespect? Yes.
To To be fair, I did misspeak. I shouldn't have said lawsuit.
I should have said settlement. Corporal of the former Twitch
trusted safety team, who spoke to Rolling Stone. Doc West set
socks now holy Don't No, don't don't hate on West Jet. Don't
hate on West Jet. I think West Jet's great.
And I I would prefer we we keep talk to him to a minimum. Unless
it's a joke. You know, it's less than a joke. Dr. Disrespect
was reported to the National Center for Missing and EXPLOITED
LIKE
>> A LOT OF MISSPEAKING, TO BE HONEST. YEAH, I'm getting
that. Dude. >> Imagine Imagine you have like a little mini
cult running for yourself where they all think you're the biggest
victim on planet Earth and you are so egregious with how stupid
you are in the stream that people are starting to be like,
what did What did you say that was correct, actually? Seems like
you just made it up." Call him an Indian. That's way funnier.
What it children the day of his ban in compliance with federal
law. The source stated they did not know if any investigation
resulted from the report. However, Twitch's own internal investigation
concluded that the messages were not septic or in violation of
child exploitation federal law. No criminal charges were filed.
Dr. Disrespect denied any wrongdoing claiming the messages were
banter and that the recipient was over the age of consent. I
don't think Dr. Disrespect is Jeffrey Epstein freaking 2.0 over
here reincarnated. But also, his response was so terrible people
were instantly suspicious because the words he edited out were
this. At first, it said individual minor and then he removed
it from his other statement. So, he removed that. He redacted
it like a [__] CIA document trying to bury it just
snapping it out of existence. So, then it read, "Were there messages
with an individual? The answer is yes." But, people were quick
to notice the edits. No, like genuinely, it was the dumbest thing
he could have done. Hold on. Hold on. I'm rolling this back 30
seconds. I need to be right back. response was so terrible
Dude, I had a tattoo and go
decide to talk about Dr. Disrespect
and just get literally every Like, I'm trying to think of something
he said that was correct.
Before I can't. I can't think of a single thing he said that
was correct. people were instantly suspicious because the words
he edited out were this. At first, it said individual minor and
then he removed it from his other statement. So, he removed that.
He redacted it like a [__] CIA document trying to
bury it just snapping it out of existence. So, then it read,
"Were there messages with an individual?" The answer is yes.
But people were quick to notice the edits. >> No, like
genuinely it was the dumbest thing he could have done. >> And again,
Tectone didn't get everything >> Who knows? There is no
proof of Dr. Disrespect ever doing anything wrong whatsoever.
The Twitch DMs were locked up and they were never shown and that
was not by Dr. Disrespect, that was by Twitch himself. >> Seems
pretty clear-cut to me. If these messages cleared the doc, wouldn't
And let's not lie. Dr. Disrespect's reputation is tainted forever.
So if these messages would clear him >> You can come back
from cheating on your wife. You absolutely can. You cannot come
back from people thinking that you're a pedo.
Yeah, you can't. That is something that you will not Oh god,
Tectone Hold on. Did Tectone get the talking points from his
spiritual advisor? Did the Tactical
Did Tactical Templar review this video,
Oh, no.
Also, Noiseworning on the link, I just noticed. Wait, what did
you link me? You linked me some [__] >> I can
come back from He lost his set? Like public reception-wise. But
if the content's good, you can, but you're never going to have
any connections. >> Exactly. He would want them out, right?
And again, there could be some legal or privacy-related issues
because the person was a minor, yada yada. I don't know. I'm
not a lawyer. The man who cheats on his wife while wearing a
wig and sunglasses is calling other men fake? Tell that to Destiny.
But you know what I mean though? Like like you can like if the
entertainment's there, you can do what you want. Um but nobody's
going to fake. Is that person arguing that Destiny should just
give up despite him still being entertaining? Cuz that's just
not true.
Destiny could easily have his stream run like clockwork. He could
have 10,000 viewers right now if he just decided to focus on
politics and ignore everything
Is like his
video games plus intermittent seething about random like
200 viewer streamers
is the reason his stream is boring as and nobody is there. That's
it.
with you publicly. You know what I'm saying? The fact that TimTheTatMan's
playing with him, it's kind of I'm like
all right, Timmy, you know? Let me rephrase it. I guess it's
not impossible. I guess it's just really hard. I guess it is
possible. You guys got me there. You guys don't you know that
that's who you're playing with? You know, you kind of judge some
of these people that they're that they're playing with. It's
like that's who that this guy this fake can tough guy the trap
guy? You're not looking at that [__] Nickmercs
who has to put Burnt Peanut in every single thumbnail when he
goes live just to stay relevant in the space. Bro, eliminated
by Dr. Cheats on wife with
The doc touching on that 10-year-old is still less offensive
and harmful than watching a single [laughter] Burnt P. I Yeah,
that that that tweet is kind of just facts.
I actually I actually probably do judge genuine Burnt Peanut
viewers more harshly than I judge Dr. Disrespect. Like it's just
Just think about it for 2 seconds. I'm that's obviously true.
10-year-old is still less offensive and harmful than watching
a single Burnt P. I really don't think the Burnt Peanut is that
poor of an entertainer. I don't. I think he's a great streamer.
>> God gives his toughest challenges If Doc was black,
nobody would even care. True.
>> What? What?
Is that just an EDP reference?
I think people cared about Lacari, man.
What the [__] is he's
Dr. He didn't do nothing. >> soldiers, but all he has to
do is just release the files unredacted. >> know what else
people want him to do to prove his innocence. By releasing the
tapes, brother. >> True. But if Yeah, but the thing is
is that he cannot do that. Right? Like those have been sealed.
So, that's not a thing that he could do. I'm I'm sure he wish
he could release that. Hey man, there's a lot of things that
I wish the public could see about me that were sealed as well.
It would make things Like what? things make a lot more sense.
But unfortunately,
I This is actually true. It's only black thugs who get the he
was a good boy, okay? He didn't do It's only It's only thugs,
okay?
Like this is absolutely true. Same with EDP. That dude them got
it. I'M NOT THE ONE WHO SEALED THEM. SO, IT'S A LITTLE bit rough,
you know what I'm saying? Disregard.
I I'm sure Doc would want to release those messages if he could.
Think he got over. Man, Dr. Disrespect,
you rookie.
Just be like me and go for Genshin Impact baddies.
They aren't 3D, so if their age is on the clock, it's okay. That's
crazy, bro. That's crazy.
Little loophole, man. God, I love anime. Again, it's in his best
interest to clear his reputation, and the easiest way to do that
would be to release all the messages or at least make it look
like you're trying to release the messages. The funniest thing
of all though is how the Doc got exposed while he was live.
Absolute cinema. Basically he just called him a pedo and he's
laughing.
This is the character, right? This is the character you have
to play. Tectone doesn't connect his like emotions to his
right? He's been reading Okay, we can't see it here, but this
is the whole point of reading Marcus Aurelius, okay?
Disconnect your emotions from your reactions, all right? None
of this is like an emotional reaction. He's laughing in a performative
way. It's all
You just got to appear confident and happy the entire time.
Is the bust? He does have the bust.
What he learned from reading Meditations, guys. A book that he
definitely read. All right, here we go. Now, let's talk about
it. Now, first of all, let me talk about what I have come to
understand based off of >> Dude, it was actually so [__]
up when I noticed it and I I immediately called that he was going
to start talking about stoicism, Marcus Aurelius, and the meditations
like all in the same stream.
Like just from just from the performative performativity of getting
this bust and putting it in frame, I immediately knew like everything
that was about to happen. He'd watch some red pill content. He
was about to talk about how actually he was letting his emotions
rule his life and he needed to get them under control, blah blah
blah, blah blah, meditation, stoicism, all this It's so [__]
predictable and boring. But the claims that I've seen online.
I have seen that Doc has tried to release the messages but cannot.
I have been told that those are sealed by Twitch, right? That
is one where I would love to get to the bottom of. That one I
cannot speak with certainty. I have only heard hearsay. So, acknowledge
that I have only heard that the messages are sealed by Twitch.
The claims of the settlement amount are hearsay as well.
The same level of hearsay. Um and those can never be released.
That is what I have been told, not by Dr. Disrespect, but by
Twitch. That is what I have heard. If there's any proof on that,
I would love to see it. Second of all, what I have seen that
is publicly verifiable data
is this.
When a creator breaches their contract, when a creator uh breaks
what is agreed upon agreed upon in their long-term business deal,
of which Dr. Disrespect has confirmed as well as Twitch has confirmed
that the he was signed to a
long-term deal on Twitch. That is confirmed. Now, if a person
has breached that contract, they can be terminated
without pay. And that's why these contracts are not paid at a
lump sum at the beginning. That's not how they work. Ask any
streamer this. Any long-term deal is not we're going to give
you $10 million right now
That is not why they're structured that way. This is This guy's
out of his [__] mind right now. Actually, the reason
your your employer doesn't give you money at the beginning of
the year is because then if you lost your job, they would
you just get to keep it? I don't like I'm pretty sure it's just
financially burdensome to pay anybody that way. I'm I'm pretty
sure that's literally the long and short of why that happens.
And then over the course of 2 years, just stream on our platform.
What it is is and let's just break it down for you. So, let's
say someone's on a He said eight figures. So, let's say lowest
end $10 million
divided by 24, which was his length, 2 years long-term. Um so,
he would have been paid $416,000
every single month, every 30 days, that's how often they pay
you, for the duration of 2 years.
Okay? Um this is all said into the public, okay? So, every single
who has validated any of this? month, he receives $416,000.
Um these are claims that he also made live on stream. If any
of these were disprovable, if Um King of Wit, this is why they
tell you if you ever win the lottery, they basically offer you
like to pay you out in in installments or a lump sum? That's
way less than the actual lottery amount. You always take the
lump sum.
It's it's worth way more than the actual like basically
almost certainly going to be worth more than whatever the actual
installment payments are. Dr. Disrespect goes live and lies about
anything about the ordeal uh involving him and Twitch, he would
be completely from the court of law. He would be completely be
able It's cuz cuz when you make the claims like that publicly
that are so easily disprovable, um you wouldn't want to risk
that reputation. Sure, maybe there is a chance that he has told
this lie for 6 months and nobody's called him out for it, but
as far as I'm concerned, any and Twitch has already gone off
the fence and many employees have come out and spoke against
him whatever he has done any misinformation. He would have been
called out for that. So, over the course of the settlement, over
the course of the uh ordeal he had with Twitch,
he could have been terminated for breaching his contract cuz
that's written That's that's boilerplate. That is written into
every single long-term contract. Ask any creator who's ever been
signed one, they will tell you the exact same thing unless they're
just
Right? Maybe don't ask every streamer cuz that sounds like
But uh you know, I I I have I have I have some experience in
writing long-term contracts when it comes to my previous affiliation
with sponsorship
So, if Dr. Disrespect was found in breach of that contract, he
would be terminated without pay.
That is not what happened.
What happened was he was terminated with
that they did not want the affiliation, but they did not have
grounds
to remove the pay. And that's what's very interesting to me.
That's what's very interesting. So, some guy in chat says, "No,
he wasn't
This was already said publicly
for over 5 6 months that Doc Like this is the impression I had
as well. So, it's weird hearing something that I think like is
pretty obvious, but again, there's just absolutely nothing that
says to me that this means Dr. Disrespect didn't do something
bad, that he wasn't sending minor trying to [__]
You could I do believe that if if Twitch were the only people
who by piercing Dr. Disrespect's privacy find out that he was
trying to [__] a minor, and then they cut him loose
for a public like purity testing elements What was the like a
code of conduct or something for some code of conduct thing with
private stuff that they had no they shouldn't have known about.
I do believe it'd be very easy for him, even if he was saying
he'd do something crazy in those DMs. There's a morality clause.
Right, right, right, right, right. Yeah. one, the settlement,
and he walked away with eight figures. Going out and saying a
lie that boisterous that no one has disproved in over half a
year
is insane. So,
that's the reason why this case interests me so much is because
I don't think Twitch has room to just throw away eight figures.
If there was any grounds to terminate him without pay, it would
have been taken. But the thing was, it wasn't, and he was paid
out in his contract in full.
So, that's the thing that I really feel like more people should
be talking about is because if he did breach his contract,
why was his pay still put out?
Because for example,
Why Why does Tectone believe that have like even if he were with
a minor,
why does Tectone believe that that's con- conduct in private
that could constitute like a reason to get rid of that that contract?
Cuz I believe they Here's the problem for them. I think if they
had just published this and then terminated, I think they might
have been fine. I think they terminated immediately. I think
that's the thing that happened. Now, that's total speculation
on my part. You don't know that that's true, but I do believe
it's because it wasn't a public spectacle, then they just banned
him. That if it had come out what he'd done, I do think he'd
be in a lot of [__] but I wonder if they basically
didn't want the risk of, you know, people getting really upset
about privacy [__] cuz I'm Yeah, I'm I'm pretty I'm
pretty confident that private can't get you axed for a
like a moral morality clause in your contract. I have lost seven-figure
deals based off of something that was
that somebody just said. You see, what do you What does he mean
disproven? Is he like on the some
Is this Wait, is this something else or is this the
This can't be the pink thing. This This cannot be the pink thing
that he's talking about. There's just no way. >> Somebody
said, "Well, Teck Ton did this." The brand said, "We don't want
to be associated in our contract. If someone makes an allegation
like that, you can be terminated." And I lost seven figures over
that. And it was wrong. It was a publicly verifiable lie
that the person even admitted later to lying about. And even
I was still terminated without pay. So, what I'm wondering is
is why would Dude, I I truly believe he's got to be referring
to something else and not the pink
Right? That has to be it. is Dr. Disrespect still paid out in
full.
I do See,
he should be more specific just to so as to not make it seem
like he might be calling Pink a liar here, right? I do believe
he get in trouble for calling Pink a liar here. >> And
I feel like a lot of people should be more interested in that
fact that he did get paid out. When it is And everybody who's
done a long-term contract should know this. It is so easy to
terminate without pay. Why was he still paid? And that's the
thing that I'm wondering about. Now, I do think if the chat logs
were ever released to the public, it would finally give us the
answer that we want. But the thing is, I have been told that
those were sealed by Twitch, not Dr. Disrespect himself.
And I'm wondering why that is. So, I just feel like there are
a lot of questions that need answers, but people are still talking
about Am I the only person in this situation?
I'm not. I'm not the only person. I'm only I'm just the only
person brave enough to say it, okay?
Am I the only one who's like Can we at least get the name? Like,
who is Who is the person? I got to see what they look like. Who
is the person that you're so enamored with in DMs that they're
like, "Hey, I'm 17." You're like, "Cool. When do you want to
meet
I just I want to see what they look like
I got to Dude, I I got to see, man. I can't be the only one who
thinks that.
Dr. Disrespect's like, "Nah, it's fine. No, I'm When do you go
to TwitchCon?"
Right? Like, that's basically just total fed posting.
Like, any If anybody ever said some [__] like that
like that to me in DMs, like, "I'm 17. Are you sure you want
to keep talking?" I'm immediately like, "No." Just on self-interest
alone. Right? On self-interest, you're immediately like, "No,
oh, never mind. We're not talking anymore." "Bro, was asking
you for pics of a minor?" No, it was like 6 years ago. They're
an adult
I'm not asking for pics of them in high school. I'm saying, "What
do they look like now?" Like Like there's like this endless amount
of undeniable proof, and there's just not. Uh and it kind of
feels like if you talk in the other direction, everybody gets
so angry at you, and then they'll just lie about why other people
should be angry at you, too. All I'm saying is before you say
someone did something, I feel like proof or evidence would be
very important.
And right now, I don't see a lot of So, that's just my opinion.
Once again, do I Do I feel like Dr. Disrespect is a wonderful
human being? No, I don't. The guy cheated on his wife. But, everything
else involving the guy is still a gray area, and I really feel
like we're treating that gray area like black and white when
it's just not.
Now, you know, it's it's it's very hard to go for a guy like
this guy. And the other thing with Lacari is, I've been told
he got investigated by the police, and his ass is not in jail.
And that's the big difference that WestJett said in the video,
that EDP's not in jail. Well, these are people who had a confirmed
police report or a police investigated him. And if a police investigates
you and finds you of wrongdoing, you're going TO GO TO JAIL.
BUT
dude, the problem is
you could run with this. There's so many bad things that you
would want to not associate with someone over that aren't illegal.
What do I know? WHAT DO I KNOW? MAY MAYBE A POLICEMAN WOULD SAY,
"YEAH, this guy kid has a legal child on his
AH, BUT WE DON'T FEEL LIKE IT. THE jail cells are full." OR YEAH,
"WE FOUND THIS GUY CONVICTED OF in a court of law with eight
policemen right there, BUT AH, >> WE'LL LET HIM WALK."
THAT LAST ONE IS HIM. I believe that last bit of hyperbole was
about him. I just don't think that's how the world is. Maybe
I'm wrong, but I I just don't think that's how the world is.
Um and I feel like a lot of people use the word
convicted convicted this, convicted
If they were convicted Nobody calls convicted rapists. What is
he making What is he making up?
Just a Just a regular old not no
descriptors, no attributes, just a regular old rapist, okay?
Not quite like his dad who's a in fact a convicted assaulter.
Although I think you can just about say convicted rapist. See,
detective I don't mind saying rapist because it is okay. I don't
know that Iron Mike I'll pick about that. convicted and investigated
by the police, why are they not in jail? Can anybody answer me
that?
Or or or do we just live in bizarro world where criminals are
just running around everywhere? Cuz the thing with the Epstein
file is all of those things are still
hearsay. None of those things are anything other than This actually
gets back to
pretty sure nothing bad happened in Epstein files. Wouldn't somebody
have gone to jail? There's no I feel like I wasn't watching the
chat. Somebody definitely made that point, chat. Nobody in the
Epstein files went to jail and now he's going to have to deal
with that one as well. And [laughter]
you know what I mean? Like
if how many times have you gone on Twitter and seen that people
say that Donald Trump is a convicted a convicted
who's eaten held civilly liable for sexual assault for Donald
Trump. children. Brother, if he was convicted in a court of law,
he would go to jail. He would go to prison. That's just not how
the world works.
Anyways, that's just my opinion. Let me know what you think.
Let me Uh not only does he think every guilty sentence is every
guilty verdict is followed by a jail sentence, Pumpernickel.
He also thinks that when the police don't or when the court system
fails to convict you, that means that's evidence that you have
done nothing wrong.
Which is not true. You're assumed innocent and they can't like
prove otherwise, but it's doesn't mean that you've been absolved,
right?
OJ case happened. Obviously the Epstein stuff happened.
Let me know if you agree or disagree. Let me know if there's
anything that I've gotten wrong. I would love to know. Anyways,
see you on the next one.
I love video. Don't forget if you might not get it, someone will.
watching the stream. He does that He does like video segments
on his stream just that exact way. I feel like he's got AI scripting
a bunch of this stuff. It's like it's loosely scripted as he
goes through it. I'm pretty sure. Anyway. Okay, I think that
is Is that it for the Tech Tone story? I think that's basically
it unless other people have reacted. I think I went and looked
to see if there were any tweets about it. See if anybody threw
up like a tweet about it or something. Give me a second.
Where do I put this? Where do I put this? Hold on. Hold on. Oh.
Dude, it's so annoying the way Twitter works sometimes.
Uh include links in text. I I like it to Grok to search Twitter
for stuff sometimes, and then it doesn't actually link the tweets
because it assumes that you can click the sources button. When
you click the sources button, this this tab sucks every time.
That's this tab is like awful. Let me guys what I'm
Tab over here is just like awful every time. Not a fan. We'll
see if there's anything interesting going on here.
11,000 views. This video by Techtone has added a layer of sound
deductive reasoning to the ongoing saga that highlights Techtone's
or sorry, Dr. Disrespect's innocence.
Really? Dislike Techtone, but I like this video. Nothing but
facts. Are we finding I feel like I'm running into a bot farm
or something here. I think I feel like I'm definitely running
into a bot farm of like for some reason. You know what I mean?
Like this is just a tweet that's going out that's supposed to
be promoting Techtone's and nobody has this opinion that somehow
Dr. Disrespect is becoming innocent reviewing Techtone's take
on Dr. Disrespect's.
Wow. No, I got nothing. I got nothing on this one. I'm going
to let it go.
And then I truly don't know. I think how much time do we have
left on the stream? We got an hour and a half.
I saw Lunar Blocks responded more to some tweets. But other than
that, I actually don't know what else is going on today. Guys,
world's our oyster, okay? World's our oyster. Throw some links
in me cuz otherwise I'm just going to keep listening to Techtone
anyway, right? >> I feel like we're speaking on a lot of
things in black and white that are still important. By the way,
I said when I started the stream, I did not do my job today.
I played video games instead of doing my job. I showed up. I
have nothing. I did the bare minimum. I hit the go live button
so that we all had something to do tonight, all right? That's
my bad, but that is what I did, okay? I'm just being I'm being
brutally honest with you guys, okay?
I was super lazy. Did you hit 70? No, I didn't even attempt to
hit 70. Oh.
Yeah, I have no I have no idea what this is, and then apparently
there's some [__] about Okay, somehow we've got to
figure out where this flesh simulator stuff starts, okay? We
get a stream background analysis for tectone setup. Oh, yeah,
sure.
We went over this before, okay?
We've got like the steer skull up here,
I'm Texan. I'm Texan. I love America. I love America. I'm I'm
Orthodox now. I'm Orthodox. Right, he's got all of these elements.
This was just picked out almost entirely as stream drops. This
is a room, by the way, in a new house he'd gone to, okay?
He had this wood paneled cabinet. I've heard this is basically
like How would I put it?
just the natural choice for like almost
right-leaning streamer right now is they get this awful wood
paneling, these these wood paneled cabinets.
Red pattern.
Okay, who's up with that bust? That's Marcus Aurelius. He Didn't
you hear that earlier, Gimli? That's Marcus Aurelius right there.
His new favorite guy, his favorite author. He read Meditations.
That's what he did in his time off. He read Meditations and he's
becoming a
Oh, you missed this? Yeah, no, when when this came out originally
I I literally pointed out that it was Marcus Aurelius and I was
like, if he I swear to god if he says that he read Meditations,
I'm going to lose it and then he leaned right into having read
Meditations and like, I'm going to now be a stoic. I'm I'm in
control of my emotions. All of this [__] It's It's
It's awful. It's genuinely awful.
Yes. Yeah, it's paint by numbers.
It's like old It It's old, too. It's like 4-year-old like He's
basically going through something of a Sneako arc, like a white
Sneako arc. 4 years after it was embarrassing for Sneako to go
through that arc publicly, okay? It's not cool. It's not good.
It's pretty bad. I think this is the origin of the flesh crash
out. Okay, can I look through this without doxxing somebody,
Vrain? Or am I going to like accidentally dox somebody on my
stream? Cuz I'd like to not do that if I could.
Is this going to Is this going to make sense? No do on that tweet.
Okay. All right. Anyway, what else we got? We got this couch.
I don't know what the deal is with this couch. Looks thrifted.
Got a rug. I don't think there's any meaning in the rug. I do
think there's a lot of meaning in him using this incredibly old
chair with this like upholstered on the edges. The The chair
is like particularly embarrassing. He He is rich as [__]
He could easily just get like a
What are they Whatever the like two $3,000 chairs are. It's a
It's two first names. Herman Miller, yeah. Herman Miller, okay.
You get an embody, you get a like a damn fair, whatever the their
different chairs are. But instead, he went to some thrift thrift
store and got the worst chair imaginable.
I have no idea why. It's crazy. We also point out the conspicuously
empty wall space where his guns would have gone.
I didn't think about that, but that is the case. He just put
the flag up like at some point after he got the room put together.
He obviously was going to put gun racks back here. That's true.
He was obviously planning to have a bunch of space for gun racks.
And then he realized he was not going to be able to get his gun
racks.
Dude, I don't even know if he had the clock up before. I think
that the flag was definitely not there.
Oh, brutal.
Good eye. Was that Tequila Sunset?
Who pulled that up? That was Tequila Sunset. Yeah, that is a
good eye that I didn't even think about that cuz he had so much
negative space here for so long. And it's the gun racks that
would have gone there.
Bro, I bet you just off screen there's like a bunch of packaging
for like Amazon ordered gun racks, too.
For sure.
Just sitting there sadly, never to be
Oh, boy.